for for the uninitiated right here's the
title addition and subtraction of
coordinates okay now if ordnance is a
word that you don't really see or it's
burned we used to see coordinates and we
think your verses like X&Y right so when
you've got coordinates of a point order
to equate you've got two values and they
describe to you exactly what you are
what's often don't realize is that this
guy over here the y-value is actually
called and coordinate the x bar has a
completely different name that's just
confusing but anyway when they say
ordinance this or is it padding
ordinance what they mean is any Y bones
okay
and the grass you're going to encounter
I hear that you're very familiar with
when you put them all together okay but
if you think about the Y values and
realizing that I'm just I'm just I need
two functions to go this is not hard at
all okay so here's what we're going to
begin we got this weed composite
function appointed composite functions
made up of two other functions okay
we're being asked to grab from naught to
seven thirty degrees okay so you can see
I've drawn the easy part here I've
broken up the composite function sine x
plus the absolute value X I've broken up
into two parts
here's my first part right oh we all
know what sine X looks like and because
I've gone from naught to 720 I've got
two copies because that's twice the
period okay now think back to when
you're doing has to value what you're
doing the absolute value for breath how
would you describe what kind of effect
would that have on this green graph when
we control the yeah very good so I'm
gonna be a little more final that is
exactly right but the parts of the graph
are reflective okay and across the
x-axis let's label that across the
x-axis is exactly right thank you fine
the part of the graph that are reflected
in are the negative parts yes so for
example see this part down here it's
going to get reflected up this part of
the key it's positive the absolute value
of a positive number is just the same
number it doesn't
okay so these bits are gonna stay the
same these bits are gonna get reflected
up that's enough
what are you guys those are just gonna
be a scrap of sheets
do you very got this one better so I'm
gonna put this one a different color um
my class is sick - that could be stated
but other colors in mathematics I'm
doing you're doing diagrams like a
superpower may help you see everything
much better
so until then really cheesy another
color so I can see what's going on okay
so if the green one is the absolute
about it's just sine of X maybe absolute
value of sine of X I'm gonna put in blue
take it even more obvious a minute okay
so as we said here's the beginning the
absolute value of sine X it's just the
same as sine X no change
but here would be a true negative but
the absolute value of a negative number
is going to be a positive number so you
see there's that just was describing
before that reflection that happens
across the x-axis and then it's periodic
every 360 degrees I've already hit 360
right there
so then what comes up after this is just
the same thing again absolute value the
positive part is just the positive part
and then this last bit it reflects okay
fantastic so now I've got my two
components on there right in fact if you
like you can even label business Hostin
helpful I've got my name three for the
original job and then it blue for the
absolute value right now I want to think
about the coordinates that's the Y
values those vertical Heights and what
happens when I add them okay so last
color let's have a look at what's knots
over here there's some easy ordinance
that you can go for right think of the
easy ones first before you do the hard
ones so for instance I've had a green
plus blue everywhere along I'm gonna add
green plus blue so might be stuck you
and X equal zero greeted blue up both
equal to zero if I stop it
so zero plus zero is gonna be zero I'm
gonna put black ants everywhere that I'm
expecting the actual whole graph to go
through right that's zero plus zero is a
whole bunch of other spots but up
zero plus zero you could see all of them
right I've got another one here another
one here another one communion okay so
far so good
those are easy right now I've got a few
more easy points that I know about as
well for instance what's the amplitude
of sine X how far to go over there if
you go one right which means the range
is negative one to one
okay so at this point here which is nine
degrees x equals nine degrees both
graphs are equal to 1 right the
ordinates those Y values are equal to 1
so if you're getting one plus one and
then natural equal to that's your
complicated so I'm going to go up here
that's not the only time it happens it
also happens over here if this was 90
degrees you go forward 360 because
that's the period of sight and that'll
be 450 I guess there you go
okay now I've got a few bits of pieces
that I could drink together now right 4
it says just have a look at the first
180 degrees of my graph right
I started 0 I come up to 2 and then I
come back to 0 it doesn't take too much
imagination to see what's going on here
right I'm gonna come up a stationary
point and come down
that's the groundbreaking I've got two
things that are increasing and
decreasing saved up and so you add them
together you get double that right in
fact for this part of the graph because
you're adding sine X to itself remember
the absolute value hasn't change the
equation of that black pot I just drew
is 2 sine X we know how to do that
that's just sine X stretch it out okay
no big deal we mentioned that it's
periodic so I'm getting the same thing
here when I go over 360 degrees okay so
again you've got it going W amplitude
but then what's really interesting what
this one happens in between right these
last pots that I haven't drawn yet
what's happening as I think that the
ornaments here here what are the
ordinance here and here they're one and
the opposite in sign is negative one
right because that's the way style works
as much and it's gonna go up it's gonna
go down okay so if I've got 1 and
negative 1 those are the ornaments you
add the together
make that zero right so I doing that in
the middle of a trip but in fact I also
do that everywhere else along this
interval right because for example this
is a week here
and this is also going to be the same
distance away from the x-axis just ones
up and what's down so everything's going
to kids or everywhere along this
interval and so here
so everywhere in here just getting this
straight line right everything cancels
out between 180 and 360 degrees right
again because it's periodic you're gonna
get the same thing happening over here
right from what's this this is my say
this was 540 it's all the way up to
there you go okay so it's a bit busy
I'll wrap right that's because I've got
so many things going up there but you
can see the really important one is the
blackboard right it starts here it is
here and it's a weird little piece but
that's good it's absolute values up kind
of like that okay
so addition subtraction ordinate is not
magic or anything like that it's just
thinking carefully slowly about well how
high is this and when I add these two
things together how do they behave as a
whole